next we have is routing in the previous
video we talked about different HTTP
methods and how they are important in
the HTTP semantic so in a way all these
HTTP methods they describe your intent
which we already talked about and you
can say these HTTP methods they express
the what of a
request your intent your action what do
you want to do on that particular
resource or what do you want to tell
your server that your intention is
whether you want to fetch some data or
add some data or update some data or
delete some data and the role of routing
is it expresses the where of a request
where do you want to send your intention
where or which resource you want to
perform your action or your intent on
you need to tell the server where do you
want to go for example you have a
request and the method is get right your
intention is fetching or getting some
data from the server
and your route path or the URL path is
slash
users and the server sends you an array
of
users okay so what you're saying is I
want to fetch some data you want to
fetch some data your action is fetching
and from where or what kind of data
right this is the resource this is the
route whatever you want to call it and
the combination of these two your
intention your action and your route the
URL parameters the address the server
takes this and this and Maps it to a
particular Handler or a set of
instructions and it performs all the
business Logic the database operations
and whatever is needed and returns you
the data and to summarize it you can say
that routing is basically mapping URL
parameters to a server side logic and
and that's all there is to it and here
we have our familiar BB Suite interface
and we have a react app which we will
use to demonstrate some of these routing
Concepts so I'll just go ahead and fire
some apis and then we can jump in and do
some analysis so the first request was a
get request and if you look at the
request and response this part we are
already familiar with this is the HTTP
method this is our intent or the action
we want to perform which is get or
patching now the this part this is what
we call the route right the address of
our request where do you want to go in
the server which is in this case / API
SL books books is called a resource and
we'll learn more about resource when we
study about rest API concepts for now we
can just assume this is a route right
and this is a route so this is our
action this is the address you want to
go to in the server and when we send
this request and the request goes
through the server responds with this
data right whatever the responses it
does not matter and for the sake of this
demo we are just sending some fillers
but typically this is what happens you
send a request the server does some kind
of authentication if it's there then it
sends the data and then in the next
request which is a post request here the
intention is post the HTTP method is
post the route is still the same/ API SL
books the request goes through it
creates another book or whatever the
resources and it returns all the
resources again in the response right so
if you notice here in the previous
request and in this request this route
part is the same so what happened is in
the previous request the request was a
get method and the route was SL API SL
books and in this request it's a post
method right and the route is still the
same/ API Das books so what happens in
the server is these two things the
method and the route these two things
are kind of a key which map to a
particular Handler in the server right
the server first checks what the method
is then it checks the route and it
concatenates these two and forms a
unique routing logic right this is a
unique path and this is another unique
path these two will never Clash right
these methods they differentiate between
the two routes and now that we know what
what basic routing is we can jump into
different types of routing right and the
first two examples that we discussed
the/ API SL books for get and post these
kind of routing or routes are called
Static routes right and why are they
call static routes for obvious reasons
because they don't have any variable
parameters inside the route and what do
I mean by variable for example this part
SL aa/ books this will stay consistent
this is a constant right we don't have
to think about a dynamic parameter
inside this route this is constant we
are always going to use this string /
API / books whenever we make the request
nothing changes in that and it is always
going to return this kind of response
that's why it's called a static route
it's a constant or it's a particular
string which never changes and it always
returns the same kind of data so in that
case what is a dynamic route so let's
fire these two requests now
and if we look at the first one so here
if you see the method is get and the
route is/ API SL users sl12 3 and in
this case this is supposed to express
the ID of the user the application of
this API endpoint is we can fetch
details of a one particular user using
the ID of the user inside the route
parameter and when we make this request
the server can extract this particular
ID from the route path and it can do
whatever operation it wants to do like
fetching the user from the database and
returning the details of the user in
this case we just the server is just
fetching the user ID and returning it in
the response to express that it got the
user ID from the route since in this
video we are not going to get too much
into the code and we just want to
understand the concepts behind it but
just to give you an idea this is what
the the route matching part in the
server looks like the server is
basically saying let's say the Handler
is called route or let's say it's
called R right R do
get and in the matching part it is
saying it's a string slash API SL
users slash colon
ID this part matches the method in the
server and this part this part matches
the route so the server is saying if any
request with the method get
and with the route slash API SL users
and in the next part any kind of string
right this Fallen ID it basically means
any kind of string that comes in this
format routed to this Handler whatever
Handler is waiting to respond to that
kind of route right so the thing to
remember is uh this convention you'll
find in any kind of servers it does not
matter it's Java or python or nodejs or
goang rust it does not matter this just
a convention find this is what I've seen
the industrywide practices mostly colon
which says it's a dynamic parameter that
the user is going to send in place of ID
the use of this is when the request
comes in our case request was / API SL
users and /1 23 the request got routed
to this part it matched with the get
right we we were sending a get request
and in the next part it matched the
first / API then the next one/ users and
it's a string right it looks like a
number but in route parameters or in
route paths whatever uh number special
characters everything is converted into
a string so this thing this gets
inserted into this slot this Dynamic
parameter slot which we are calling as
ID if you read it it's clearly readable
right you can read it like you're saying
patch me some data because it's get and
where is that data that is in/ API SL
user
and whose data that is it is with of the
user with ID 1 2 3 right it's clearly
readable that's the whole idea of rest
apis because it it it provides a human
readable construct to routing this is
called a dynamic route and the
terminology that we use is this part is
called a route parameter or path
parameter that is something to remember
we have like two different types of
parameters that's a little confusing one
is these kinds of parameters these kinds
of dynamic parameters are called path
parameters because they go right after
the forward slash right it is part of
the route that's why they are called
path parameters or route parameters and
the next one we have query param so for
this we can just type out something
let's
say some value and let's hit this
API and we if we look into this API this
is what it looks like this is the method
and this is the route right this whole
part is the route basically the route
is/ API SL
search question mark
query equals
to sum plus
value and now I realize this is more
readable here than here but anyway we'll
make do so this part we understand right
this is the route / API SL search this
is the address that we want to go into
the
this is the part that server uses to
match including the method and this
route this is the part the server uses
to match it to some Handler and it
performs the logic and returns some data
which is not important the thing to
focus here is the query part here the
question mark and the key and the value
this is called query parameter that's
the terminology and next is the
application why do we use it because in
post requests or in put requests we have
the body of the request right we get to
use the body and we can use the body to
send some kind of data send parameters
that we want to attach into the request
we have some kind of container to send
some user defined values into the server
but in case of get request in rest API
get requests don't have a body you want
to send some value in the get request so
let's say you can say that we can send
those values in the path parameters
right but path parameters serve a
particular purpose right they serve as a
semantic expression right in the
previous request that we saw we were
saying SL API SL users SL1 23 and the
semantic meaning here is we want to
fetch the details of a user whose ID is
1 2 that is the semantic expression in
the path parameter but if we want to say
we want to call this API which is/ API /
search and we want to say the search
value is some random value uh that the
user has typed into the input box how do
you want to send it let's suppose we
want to send it in the path parameter
what will it look like SL API SL search
and Slash the value in this case it will
be some
value some value technically technically
it's possible you can do this but it's
it's very hard to maintain and it it it
defeats the whole purpose of rest API
right providing semantic Expressions to
AP end points it defeats the whole
purpose that's why we have this concept
called query parameters in query
parameters we can send a set of key
value pairs in a request typically we
use it with get request because we don't
have a body to send data in so in get
request we get these thing called query
parameters which are key value pairs
that we can send to the server to let to
send some kind of metadata about the
request for example let's say it's a
request about fetching paginated data
you want to petch a list of books which
are paginated we have not gotten into
pagination yet but I'm pretty sure you
must have encountered it at some point
they basically look like this so let's
say it's a endpoint which fetches a list
of books in paged format so it looks
something like this SL API SL books and
when you hit it the server returns an
object or a Json and inside data you
have whatever the a list of an array of
books and it returns some a set of
metadata about the response right and it
looks something like this like
total current
page and total
Pages things like this it depends on the
implementation but something like this
so the purpose of this is and you also
have a limit here purpose of this is the
server will paginate the data the
response and it will send a chunk of
data let's say the limit is 20 there's
some kind of default limit so what the
server will do is it will send 20 books
from the start and it will let you know
how many books are there in total let's
say 100 books and what is the current
page which is the page one and what are
the total pages and if you divide 100 by
20 it will be like five pages right
these are all the kinds of values you'll
receive from the server and the client
can use these parameters use this
response metadata to make the subsequent
requests accordingly according to the
client's needs how how can it fetch the
next page in the next page it can do/
API SL books and in the query parameter
it can do page equals to two right
because by default the server send the
page one we did not have to send any
request any query parameter for the
value of page or limit but in the second
request we want do we want to tell the
server that we want the response for
page two so in a get request we can send
that information using query parameters
this is one application usually API send
different kinds of parameters in the
query for example you want to filter by
some user defin parameter you want to
sort it what is the order you want to
sort in whether it is ascending or
descending all these kinds of
information will go inside query
parameters in in the form of key value
so that is basically the uses and the
definition of quy parameters and this is
what the API typically looks like next
we have is nested route this is not
really a type of routing it's just a
practice that you will see everywhere
because in rest apis for a semantic
expression we often have to resort to
nesting right nesting different types of
resources and the nested route is
typically the result of that and if we
hit this API and want to see what it
looks like this is what the request and
response looks like so what it says is
is is the get request and this is the
route uh we can say this is the static
part of the route and this is one
Dynamic route parameter or path
parameter and this is the second Dynamic
path parameter and the application of
this is and why do we do this because
again to express the semantic meaning so
what we are saying here is we want to do
a get operation
on
this route right let's say/ API /
users with the user whose ID is 1 2 3
you want to fetch the details of this
user so semantically the first part
expresses that we are fetching
information or data which is related to
this user and the second part says we
are again fetching the posts of that
user and to go one level deep again you
are fetching a a particular post which
is the post with ID 456 we can stop at
different phases here okay let's see so
the first part the static part is/ API
SL users this is a static part and this
in itself is one route which we saw
earlier it it it returns a result right
if you do/ API SL users it will return
list of all users because that's the
Handler of that match is doing right if
we go one level deep again/ API SL users
SL1 23 and this is a unique route in
itself because we added a dynamic
parameter and in the server s side it
will see the get method and it will
match with a different Handler right and
that Handler will return the information
of this user whose ID is 1 12 3 so this
is one level of nesting we can go
further which is/ API SL users SL SL1 23
and/
posts and now at this point what the Ser
will seees it's a get method and we are
it will match with a Handler which
returns all posts of a particular user
because we stopped here right and this
expresses a different meaning
altogether we are fetching the posts of
a user with ID 1 2 3 all the users posts
right and and in this demo what we are
doing is SL API SL users SL1 23 SL posts
SL
456 and what this is saying we want to
fetch data of user with ID 1
123 what do we want to fetch we want to
fetch the posts and not all post we want
to fetch a particular post with the ID
456 so for obvious reasons this is
called a nested route right because we
Nest different types of information in
different levels to express different
semantic meanings and it results in
different kinds of responses all right
that's all there is to it in nested
routing it's pretty convenient and you
will see it getting used pretty much
everywhere if the API is even has a
medium level of complexity next up we
have an interesting concept called route
versioning and deprecation so let's just
fire these two apis and we'll jump into
the concept of
that okay so if you look into
this so this looks pretty much like our
earlier request except it has this
keyword which is V1 it it says API slv1
SL products and if you look at the
second request it says V2 right so this
is called route versioning it is a very
common practice in API endpoints uh
servers which has a rest API uh
interface and the the use of this is if
we look at these two requests and
responses for that we'll understand why
do we use versioning in servers right in
API endpoints if you look at the
response of this we are saying / API
slv1 products and this is what the
response looks like it has field data
and and it has an array and each array
has an object Json with ID name price ID
name price right and in the second
request which is the V2 request we have
again data and we have ID title price
right in the first one we had ID name
price in the second one we have ID title
price and now it is a pretty trivial
example usually the use of versioning is
let's say you have an API endpoint and
you are returning data in a particular
format right and later on new
requirements came in let's say you were
earlier serving a web app and future in
the future you are serving a react
native app right an Android app or a
flutter app for that entity or that
device you had to change the response of
your data so your first option is
changing the whole route right changing
the whole route matching part so let's
say you can say/ API SL new products
right or what you can do is you can add
that to your versioning you can say in
the version one of our API we were
serving responses in this format and new
requirements came in and in version two
we are serving in this format one thing
it expresses your intention very clearly
you have the version one of response
your version one of response and you
have version 2f response the second part
is you did not have to change your whole
route you did not have to do/ API SL new
products using this versioning concept
you can even eventually deprecate V1 you
can let's say uh send a notice to your
front end Engineers that after the V2 is
released V1 is deprecated so in the next
release all the engineers can eventually
migrate to V2 so they have this window a
particular window where they have the
opportunity to migrate the request
endpoints to the V2 format and
eventually you will completely get rid
of V1 and you'll make the V2 to V1 right
so you have a very stable and complete
workflow to add new structure to your
API endpoints add breaking changes to
your API endpoints using this workflow
and your engineers your client have
window where they have the opportunity
to migrate into the new structure that's
the use of route versioning and
deprecation in the end we have something
called catch all route so if we hit
this and if we look at the request and
in
response so we what we are doing here is
we are sending requests to a route which
the server does not serve for right we
are doing SL a/ V3 SL products at this
point the server does not serve
responses for this route right it does
not have an Handler it does not cater to
requests coming into this endpoint so
typically what the server will do is in
the end after serving all the different
routes and all the methods uh associated
with those route in the end it will do
is slash
star whatever request after going
through all the previous route matching
algorithms whatever request reaches here
this part it will be mapped to a Handler
and that Handler will send a
userfriendly message that this route
which you are requesting this route does
not exist right this route are not found
so instead of just sending a null
response which is the default Behavior
if you don't do a catch all handling we
are just sending a userfriendly message
to let the client know that we don't
cater to this endpoint that's all catch
all route is about and with that we have
covered pretty much all the concepts
that one needs to know before diving
deep into different kinds of routing and
all the components of routing like query
parameters path parameters and all the
nested Dynamic parameters and that's all
pretty much you need to know to get into
a backend code base and and understand
the routing parts and make changes to it
and add new things